l'un des organisateurs du tournoi
international d'aéromodélisme des
clayes-sous-bois qui s'ouvre demain est
donc l'invité de cette édition du 7 8
pour débuter cette édition les clés du
ciel c'est le nom de votre club piloté
c'est le cas de le dire ce rendez vous
cela fait quatre ans que vous
l'organiser vous avez réussi en quatre
ans donc avec la quatrième édition à
l'imposer ainsi et en faire un rendez
vous incontournable comment vous avez
réussi en fait c'est laisser les pilotes
qui ont fait ça c'est le bouche à
oreille c'est et pilotes dont la
première année on avec l'organisation
soit à la hauteur tout à fait oui c'est
un sacré travail c'est effectivement
mais bon c'est principalement les plots
djoudi qui le bouche à oreille sont
venus et ça c est ça c'est celui dans
toute l'europe et au tel point que cette
année pour la 4 pour la première fois
nous aurons un chinois parce que jusqu'à
présent ce sont des européens et
s'affronter et là vous aurez un
compétiteur chesneau chinoise ans qui
est venu spécialement pour l'eee top
alors c'est pas la seule nouveauté est
ce qu il yad autres nouveautés aussi
attendre pour ceux qui viennent eux
aussi en spectateur parce que c'est
ouvert au public c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on en parle si vous souhaitez
découvrir un petit peu plus cette
discipline voilà il a plu beaucoup plus
je tiens précise tout de suite que
l'entrée est gratuite pour public
tellement important et voilà c'est quand
même important donc la nouveauté de
cette année c'est qu'on a lu les
premiers championnats du monde de la
discipline qui se sont déroulés en
allemagne à cobourg
le champion du monde est un autrichien
qui sera présent à l'ifop et la france
et est arrivée première par équipes est
champion du monde juniors donc l'eeetop
c'est le nom de cette compétition
internationale international indoor
tournament of parmi sa part donné à
cette dimension internationale forcément
il fallait un nom anglais d'ailleurs que
vous dites paris et vous dites pas les
clayes-sous-bois dont l'appellation
officielle non non c'était c'était aussi
l'objectif c'était un peu pour donner
une image de paris parce que bon c'est
vrai que les clayes-sous-bois vu par un
lituanien ou un biélorusse et c'est
parce que c'est paris ça parce que ça
arrive forcément ça parle des essais ça
a été fait le nom a été déterminé en
accord avec la mairie des clés et vous
avez à travailler sur ce tournoi cette
compétition depuis plusieurs années la
préparation se fait très longtemps
d'ailleurs en avance vous avez commencé
dès le mois de septembre à 12 mois de
septembre a préparé un petit peu combien
de compétiteurs vous attendez alors pour
cette édition de cette année nous avons
cinquante compétiteurs de sept
nationalités différentes
comment se définit l'aéromodélisme parce
qu'on parle d'une discipline que
peut-être le plus grand public ne
connaît pas non tout à fait
l'aéromodélisme j'irai dans en général
c'est une passion de l'aviation une
passion du modélisme et de faire voler
des plus lourds que l'air construit de
ses mains et sa touche de plus en plus
de personnes qui sont passionnés par ce
par ses maquettes une fois et qu'ensuite
on fait voler la fédération nationale 27
mille adhérents 800 adhérents dans le
département des yvelines c'est les
chiffres que nous avions évoqué l'an
dernier puisque vous étiez aussi vous
nous présenter cette compétition où ils
ont peu bougé c'est resté à peu près à
ce niveau là et comment se placent la
france alors par rapport aux autres pays
elle est très bien placé mais parce que
là c'est une compétition internationale
mais ce que la france figure bien en
général les commandes en général de la
france
se passe très bien dans toutes les
compétitions et les premières en voltige
aérienne extérieur on s'en rappelle la
f3 on est bien bien placé on est
premiers aussi je crois en planeur tous
à radiocommande et bien entendu et donc
voilà il envoie des images de l'an
dernier l'an dernier le bilan avait été
plutôt bon comment s'était classé
notamment le club des clayes-sous-bois
alors votre club parce que vous avez
participé oui moi j'ai participé mais
moi je participe dans la catégorie la
plus basse on a trois catégories
promotion nationale internationale moi
je concours en promotion chez à regret
4e et les autres du clae on est des clés
on était cinq à concourir donc nicolas
le premier était dixième de sa catégorie
donc la catégorie internationale à noter
que le même nicolas piétu cette année a
fini quatrième au championnat du monde
donc ils se sont déroulés vous l'avez
dit en allemagne en allemagne cette
année c'était en allemagne c'était la
première fois c'était la première fois
les championnats du monde ça veut dire
que on va en parler de plus en plus
forcément parce que là ça sent stable
dans ce championnat championnats
européens pardon francs championnats
mondiaux qui se sont déroulés en
allemagne jusqu'à où ça va aller les
romains deleasa pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas non mais le lindor donc ce qu'on
appelle lindor c'est quelque chose qui
est très bien qui se met en place et qui
a de plus en plus d'importance parce que
ça permet de pratiquer l'aéromodélisme
par tout temps puisque ça se pratique
dans un gymnase avec des avions qui
coûtent très peu cher donc ça coûtait en
moyenne si on se lance dans cette danse
est plus dans lindor il faut compter la
radio plus à lyon il faut compter près
de son bureau et ensuite on doit
investir régulièrement pour mettre à
jour entretenir oui bien sûr mais il ya
très peu de casse parce que comme les
avions sont très légers entre 80 et 120
grammes même quand il tape dans un mur
ou dans un panneau de basket ce qui
arrive relativement souvent il ya ces
poteaux et très peu de casse et un avion
coûte à peu près une centaine de re in
60 10 euros les compétiteurs ne font que
ça ils consacrent leur vie à ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui de modélisme des
compétitions non mais c'est en plus ça
reste une patience et une passion c'est
des amateurs il ya pas de
professionnalisme dans cette branche est
d'ailleurs les concours que ça soit
championnats du monde ou l'eeetop il n'y
a absolument pas de
l'aspect pécunier pour les gagnants vous
allez participer encore cette année tout
à fait avec l objectif de faire mieux
premier
dans la catégorie on m'avait promotion
catégorie promotion qui est la première
dès la première avec des figures
relativement simple pour justement
rentrer un peu dans cette compétition et
voir ce que ça donne c'est
principalement des des buts c'est
destiné à la promotion aux très jeunes
ou alors ou très anciens voilà et vous
vous situez dans quelle catégorie non je
vous poserai pas ces pièces ont parlé
des compétiteurs delà du temps qu'ils
consacraient à leur machine par exemple
vous votre expérience combien de temps
vous passez pour préparer non pas la
compétition championnat mais préparez
votre machine la machine monseigneur
relativement vite vite fait à monter il
faut en un week-end a vu comme ça c'est
monté par contre il y avait quand même
l'entraînement au vol au maniement et
moi personnellement je vole entre 4 et 5
heures tous les samedis dans tous les
samedis va consacrer une période de
votre temps à faire voler ses différents
engins que l'on voit d'ailleurs évolué à
ce que le public vient aussi juste pour
découvrir oui de fonds gardé évoluer
parce qu'il ya des balles et ses treks
c'est une chorégraphie dirais que la
compétition indoor je compare ça au
patinage artistique c'est qu'il ya des
des figures imposées il voltige imposé
et côté de ça il ya du vol en musique
donc des acrobaties assez époustouflante
par jour parfois sur une musique choisie
par le concurrent il ya des juges aussi
il ya des juges des jeux alors comment
sont choisis les juges qui officie à
bosser des juges officiels c'est une
fédération qui détermine nous sommes
balle nous sommes affiliés à la ffm qui
la fédération française d'aéromodélisme
et l'eeetop en plus et inscrites à la
fcic la fédération aéronautique
internationale et donc les juges avec
leurs critères très précis qui vont
décider des champions de cette année que
vous pourrez aller rencontrer à partir
de demain la compétition débute demain
vendredi aux clayes-sous-bois un mot
pour faire venir le public peut-être
venez découvrir ce set ce loisir
merveilleux et très sympathique merci à
vous rendez vous aux clayes-sous-bois
pour cette compétition d'aéromodélisme
indoor j'ordonne les dates 1 du 15 au 17
mars merci je remédie du sport à suivre
avec deux équipes du stade français
c'est du rugby qui se déplace à montigny
le bretonneux ce week end mais déjà don
du sang une des conséquences inattendues
des intempéries est la chute du nombre
de donateurs des collectes mobiles ont
dû être annulés les besoins quotidiens
en ile-de-france ne sont pas assurés
katherine hull a tôt fait le point
devant un centre commercial amour par
michael massa vient donner son sang pour
la première fois dans la salle d'attenté
il remplit un questionnaire avant d'être
reçu par des médecins pour un entretien
couverts par le secret médical
ce dernier va déterminer si michael est
autorisé à donner son sang est la
quantité qu'on va pouvoir lui prélever
en fonction de son poids et de sa taille
pour le jeune homme se sera 480
millilitres le maximum je suis passé
devant et puis j'avais jamais donné puis
ma copine masi bas salaires donc on va
aller faire nos achats et puis j'ai
donné j'ai toujours voulu le faire mais
jamais l'occasion que comme j'ai pas
peur des équipes une fois le prélèvement
terminé la poche de sang et récupérées
et traitées dans les douze heures elle
va d'abord subir des analyses
biologiques précise en vérifiant
maintenir à son
niveau des maladies on vérifie à vih les
hépatites et la syphilis jamais avait
quelque chose d'anormal
la poche de sang de michael sera
transférée sur des sites de production
est divisé en plaquettes plasma et
globules donner son sang un geste qui
prend une dizaine de minutes rapide et
sans douleur surtout indispensable des
groupes sanguins sont plus recherchées
que d'autres au moins et ab mais en
réalité existe 33 system générique
différent dans le sens on sait jamais de
quoi on peut avoir besoin dans la vie on
peut en avoir besoin nous mêmes pour
dijon scène du sein d'un grave accident
c'est pour sauver les gens le sang est
un médicament unique parce qu' il ne
peut être fabriqué que nos frères
humains et qu' il sert principalement
aux urgences bien entendu mais aussi à
permettre des chimiothérapies chez tous
les malades qui souffrent de cancer ou
de leucémie alors les besoins de sang en
ile de france sont de l'ordre de 1500
traitement par jour actuellement on est
largement de sa 1 2 ch est entrée
quotidienne
de dons en raison des intempéries de ces
derniers jours les collectes mobiles de
sang ont été diminués par deux les
honneurs sont donc invités à se rendre
sur les lieux fixes commotionné quant à
mickaël on le retrouve en fin de
collecte à la pause collation pour une
première bilan de ce très bien passé
donc je pense que je recommencerai
les hommes peuvent donner au maximum six
fois leur sens dans l'année 4 fois pour
les femmes